Hawthorne is a well nurtured small
island where everything is run and
controlled by chef
the menu is a film about a bonka chef
who decides to go out in Flames really
and everything in the design every idea
every item every palette within that
building we wanted to be created
specifically to represent the vision of
chaslowic Ray finds character and on
that note food for him food is like a
religion he is the master so he watches
the kitchen prepare the food that he's
created or designed when you walk into
Hawthorne you see that everything has
been chosen for a reason the attention
to detail is unparalleled it's
interesting because it's an experience
and all of us other than Margot really
are there for the experience of it
food is theater food is comedy food is
drama food is satire the flavors are
there it's very clean it's very um
thalassic
thalassic Oceanic the idea that you're
pairing that experience with the
structure of a film made perfect sense
to me that's
I didn't really know this world so I
needed people who did your eyes are on
everything everything I saw the chef's
table about Dominique creton was
completely taken with her and her whole
vibe and spirit and then Mark said oh
she's going to design the food so I was
very excited about that Dominique crenn
is this extraordinary artist literally
one of the best chefs in the world in
fact the first woman in America to win
three Michelin stars this is a part of
making sure that everyone is on the same
ledge it was important to also get a
sense of who he was as a chef so is food
tell a story of who he is I think that
Dominique cran did a brilliant job in
designing the dishes there's a certain
kind of like aggression to them in
certain senses which I really like we
specifically wanted Chef slowex
Creations to be beautiful but somewhat
dead so that enabled Dominique in
creating the menu to not create a
Dominique cran menu but to create a
chessler menu to play the role
yes
we recruited a team of people all of
whom had experience in kitchens and we
gave them roles according to their
experience in a well-run kitchen
everyone knows precisely their place
both in the hierarchy and the physical
space that they're stationed waiting in
five
I love you all
the terracol element was obviously take
that into an almost kind of militaristic
Zone but we had to make sure that what
they were doing at every moment
throughout the film was authentic and
actually correct whatever we were
cooking on the stoves or the grill or
anything was always what the next course
was so it really did look like you were
planning the night red it is and has
always been the food of the Common Man
and so tonight
you get no bread
David gelp the creator of Chef's Table
did a weekend in Adam McKay's offices
and some of my favorite shots in the
film came from that weekend and I really
felt as we dropped these shots in the
balance of the film was just
fundamentally right at that point it was
a huge moment for me we really wanted to
treat it seriously even though the film
is very funny we wanted the food to be
like deadly serious and so we used all
the tools that we use on a chef's table
food Beauty shoe to achieve that being a
part of it was just a dream come true
it's exciting food connect people and
you can tell a story through it we
always cook with love don't we
everyone knows love is the most
important ingredient
[Music]